when you think of Natural History
Museum's you probably picture exhibits
filled with ancient lifeless things like
dinosaurs meteorites and gemstones but
behind that educational exterior which
only includes about 1 percent of a
museum's collection there are hidden
laboratories where scientific
breakthroughs are made beyond the
unmarked doors and on the floors the
elevators won't take you to you'd find
windows into amazing worlds this maze of
halls and laboratories is a scientific
sanctuary that houses a seemingly
endless variety of specimens here
researchers work to unravel mysteries of
evolution cosmic origins and the history
of our planet one Museum alone may have
millions of specimens the American
Museum of Natural History in New York
City has over 32 million in its
collection let's take a look at just one
of them scientists have logged exactly
where and when it was found and used
various dating techniques to pinpoint
when it originated repeat that a million
times over and these plants animals
minerals fossils and artifacts present
windows into times and places around the
world and across billions of years of
history when a research problem emerges
scientists peer through these windows
and test hypotheses about the past for
example in the 1950s populations of
predatory birds like peregrine falcons
owls and eagles started to mysteriously
crash to the point where a number of
species including the bald eagle were
declared endangered fortunately
scientists in the Field Museum in
Chicago had been collecting the eggs of
these predatory birds for decades they
discovered that the eggshells used to be
thicker and had started to thin around
the time when an insecticide called DDT
started being sprayed on crops DDT
worked very well to kill insects but
when birds came and ate those heaps of
dead bugs the DDT accumulated in their
bodies
it worked its way up the food chain and
was absorbed by apex predator birds in
such high concentrations that it thinned
their eggs so that they couldn't support
the nesting birds weight
there were omelettes everywhere until
scientists from the Field Museum in
Chicago and other institutions helped
solve the mystery and saved the day
America thanks you Field Museum Natural
History Museum's windows into the past
have solved many other scientific
mysteries Museum scientists have used
their collections to sequence the
Neanderthal genome discover genes that
gave mammoths red fur and even pinpoint
where ancient giant sharks gave birth
there are about 900 Natural History
Museum's in the world and every year
they make new discoveries and insights
into the Earth's past present and future
museum collections even help us
understand how modern threats such as
global climate change are impacting our
world for instance natural ists have
been collecting samples for over a
hundred years from Walden Pond famously
immortalized by Henry David Thoreau
thanks to those natural ists who count
Thoreau among their number
we know that the plants around Walden
Pond are blooming over three weeks
earlier than they did a hundred and
fifty years ago because these changes
have taken place gradually one person
may not have noticed them over the span
of a few decades but thanks to museum
collections we have an uninterrupted
record showing how our world is changing
so the next time you're exploring a
Natural History Museum remember that
what you're seeing is just one gem of a
colossal scientific treasure trove
behind those walls and under your feet
are windows into forgotten worlds and
who knows one day some future scientist
may peer through one and see you
you